inflation came in at a 40-year high this
past week and bitcoin everyone wants to
know what is going on is it an inflation
hedge asset is it a safe haven well this
episode of the on-chain metrics
breakdown every saturday morning is
brought to you by ftx so let's go ahead
and dive right into the actual metrics
first if we take a look at bitcoin we
can see that it's trading just below 30
000 or so it's down 2.83 over the last
24 hours then if we take a look at the
actual network itself we can see that
the market cap of bitcoin sits at 550
billion dollars the current inflation
rate is at 1.76 percent 90 of all
bitcoin has already been issued into the
circulating supply the real exchange
volume over the last 24 hours is 3.8
billion dollars miners have been paid 27
million over the last 24 hours to
continue to secure the decentralized
network of bitcoin the gbtc premium is
actually a discount it's down more than
25
from its nav and of course bitcoin is
down 57 from its all-time high if we
then go ahead and we compare bitcoin
gold and the s p 500 over the last year
bitcoin's down 20 and gold and s p are
negative as well but over a two to ten
year time frame bitcoin continues to
drastically outperform both of these
other assets then if we take a look at
the price what we can see is that
bitcoin at this point has traded above
this level for 507 days in its entire
life that means 89 of the time if you
had bought bitcoin and held till today
you would be up in terms of u.s dollar
value
then if we go ahead and we take a look
at bitcoin compared to other assets we
can see bitcoin versus gold s p 500
nasdaq and tlt bitcoin's compound annual
growth rate is 135
drastically outperforming the other
assets and bitcoin's five year sharp
ratio continues to dominate sitting at
1.11 meaning that if you take bitcoin
and you put it into a portfolio it has a
number of advantageous properties now of
course looking at the actual metrics of
bitcoin in terms of its network health
and its comparison on a financial
standpoint to other assets is helpful
but let's dig into on-chain metrics and
no one does it better than the team over
at blockwear and will clemente first we
can start out with a price temperature
of bitcoin and to illustrate the
significance of this current drawdown
what we see is that many standard
deviations of market price is near a
four-year trend bitcoin approaching that
year trend which sits just above 21 000.
next up we can go ahead and take a look
at short-term holders and the percentage
of total supply and profit held by those
short-term holders it continues to
re-test its historical lows
then we can switch and take a look at
one of the lowest readings in short-term
holder profit loss ratio and we can see
that we continue to sit firmly below the
neutral level as we take a look at
traditional bear market behaviors we can
see that short-term holders both
capitulate and age past that
155-day threshold into long-term holders
and so if we take a look looking at the
on-chain cost basis we see that on-chain
cost bases coming closer and closer with
price
another bottom signal that they continue
to watch is that they're looking at the
market price pushing below the
aggregated realized price and so what
you can see here is that it's getting
close the team over at blockwear doesn't
want to sound like a broken record these
last few weeks but there's not much to
do but simply wait
on the derivative side they don't see
anything really changing the spot
premium to futures has persisted for
months now and one of the longest
regimes of which in bitcoin's history
then if you take a derivative of premium
the aggregated funding rates for
perpetual futures those remain muted as
well
next up if we take a look at hash price
what we can see is that the miners are
essentially short hash rate short
difficulty and long the bitcoin price
and with that in mind minor margins have
been getting broadly compressed with
hash rising difficulty rising and the
price dropping if we go ahead and take a
look at that marching compression we can
see that it's led to some selling of
inventory from miners something to keep
an eye on and it will be expanded upon
more in the mining sector in the future
remarkably though the amount of bitcoin
supply that hasn't moved in at least a
year continues to climb and now we are
at an all-time high
65.5
of all bitcoin circulating supply has
not moved in at least a year
and lastly that asian trading premium
that we've been talking about for the
last couple of weeks it's starting to
come down slightly and something that
has been a good signal over the last two
years and everyone will continue to
monitor the team over at blockwood does
a great job with the on-chain metric and
i highly suggest that you go ahead and
subscribe to their newsletter and of
course you yourself using on-chain
metrics or a variety of other tools can
go look at the various data points on
the blockchain yourself speaking of
yourself one of the things i think you
should go check out is ftx ftx has got a
great product not only is the user
interface very friendly and easy and
simple to navigate but on top of that
they've got some of the best pricing in
the entire crypto market many times
they're 85 cheaper than any of their
competitors on top of having great
liquidity and great pricing ftx is also
now starting to use digital stocks which
are in beta you'll be able to trade
crypto and stocks all from one place the
stocks will have no transaction fees and
no payment for order flow so you get
better pricing and on top of that
between today and monday morning at 10
a.m eastern ftx is going to be giving
out 10 000. two people will win five
grand all you have to do is go into the
description click on the link open an
ftx account and they'll randomly select
two people each one will get five
thousand dollars that's awesome from
ftxus i hope you guys enjoy their
product i hope you enjoy these updates
and i'll see you guys next saturday